reg was on the call last night as a
needed double overtime but the Raptors
are still a lot good morning reg how are
you luxury not a necessity to your
question I think winning a championship
I think most people especially because
you know I told you I have Milwaukee
winning the whole thing I think if they
could win it without Kevin Durant I
think that would show a lot of people
yeah Kevin Durant is the best player on
your team
he was a luxury to have but he wasn't a
necessity to have to win that
championship I also think Steph Curry
doesn't get enough credit or
acknowledgement because he had to
sacrifice his game to allow Kevin Durant
to fit into this lineup because as Steph
goes than everybody else go so I think
everybody followed Steph's lead but
Steph act we asked to Kevin Durant to
make this a little bit smoother than it
probably would have gone with other
teams reg and think about what you're
saying you're talking about a two-time a
two-time most valuable player who had to
take a step back to let another MVP
probably grab the reins and be the face
of that team so it shows you the
selflessness of Steph Curry and of the
Warriors but I've always said no the
Warriors are the most dangerous when
Steph Curry is on the floor and healthy
because teams adjust far differently to
him than they would Kevin Durant because
as soon as he crosses half-court he's
alive
and he just he puts other teams and
especially the pigs the Centers of the
power forts in very difficult positions
on those high screen and rolls as we saw
in Games one and two
what Portland was trying to do are they
sagging off are they going to show are
they gonna drop are they gonna hard
hedge are they gonna try to double the
it's a nightmare with Steph Curry
because he's live anywhere on the floor
and then on top of that
he's running ragged off all those
screens you jump out on them there slips
I mean the assist that draymond Green is
getting a lot of those are because of
the reaction of how they are guarding
Steph and klay coming off those Street
talking to Reggie Miller on the call
last night double overtime bucks in the
Raptors what was Drake telling the Greek
freak I don't know but be careful what
you say it's funny because Yanis didn't
pay any attention but Drake was having
ongoing conversations with the whole
bunch teams and it was great theater to
watch because again being in that
situation and haven't gone through it
with Spike you love when the fans are
engaged like that but just be careful
what you read because Yanis had a
terrible game and give all the credit to
Nick nurse and the Raptors the big
adjustment he was going to start and
play more with quiet renard on the Greek
Creek and they built a wall all night
long and even during those two overtimes
every time he was to spin the basketball
and get into the lane he was gonna see
bodies and I thought it was very
frustrating for Yanis because he
couldn't get off his shot and he was a
very reluctant to take the outside shot
struggled from the field 5 of 16 over 3
from downtown we know he's not a great
shooter he doesn't trust his jump shot
so 12 points he did have 23 rebounds
which was very impressive but it wasn't
the type of game that we've seen from
object to Coombe both throughout these
playoffs especially his last three road
games he has averaged 37 points 21 of
those points averaging and coming from
the pain so a frustrating night for the
Greek Creek who's more important to
their team the Greek freak or kowai
kowai kowai is is Michael Jackson the
rest of those dudes Tito Randy Jermaine
it's quiet because Milwaukee they play
90 and coach bud has those guys
I wouldn't say on a minutes restriction
but they know their minutes so they're
well-rested that's why I think coming
into Game four it will favor Mill
because Pascal ciacco and Clyde
Leonard's they had to play heavy minutes
last night and quite plain even though
no one is saying there's an injury he
was clearly affected by something on his
leg
and he plays 52 minutes last night and
they eat down a victory so unless they
can get some more shooting from Danny
Green from Fred vanvleet I think Norman
Powell was great off the bench but I
mean if you look at Danny Green and Fred
been asleep a combined two of 20 mm-hmm
I mean that that can't happen
combined to a 20 from the field combined
two of 14 from three and you find a way
to win that ballgame so they got big
time efforts from Gasol Gasol finally
showed up in the series and made big
shot but you would have to think in Game
four because of the depth of Milwaukee
the bad game by Yanis he has always come
about back in bounce back after a tough
night that it was favored Milwaukee but
this is why you play the ballgame right
now Kawhi Leonard fourth straight thirty
point point game for the Raptors the
Raptors are you know playoff record he's
a machine right now I saw this story and
it came out of New York Newsday Steve
popper is the reporter he said that a
person close to the Lakers believes the
team hired Jason Kidd as an assistant
coach to lure the Greek freak and free
agency keep in mind the Greek freak is
under contract through the 2021 season
no kid coach the great freak for three
now has a hole to get to you in a moment
red kid he coached the Greek freak for
three and half seasons in Milwaukee and
I guess they have a close relationship
is there any credence to this story in
your opinion reg absolutely not and I
will agree that they do have a great
relationship we called a couple games
when Jay kid was the coach and you could
see the the relationship between the two
actually helped him get that big Nike
deal as well so I know the relationship
is there but from all vacations and
everything that has come out of Yanis
valve about his love and his love affair
for Milwaukee in that fan base I
absolutely do not see him ever leaving
Milwaukee to go to the Lakers I could be
wrong but they have built a team that
could endure for a very long time in
Milwaukee in a small market and to have
a up-and-coming face of the league like
he honest in a small market it was very
much like our LeBron was in Cleveland he
could rule the day he could rule the
East LeBron is no longer in the East he
could be the face of the Eastern
Conference unless known Kevin Durant
goes into your work and that kind of
changes the complexity of the Eastern
Conference landscape but right now the
honest is sitting on the game of thrones
right so I do not I would never see him
going to the Lakers but I could be wrong
the relationship is there between the
two but right now Yanis is sitting
pretty and a team that's built around
him a young team and everyone knows
their roles and he is the catalyst and
he's selfless and unselfish to a halt by
finding these guys it's the perfect game
for him
do you watch Game of Thrones I do not I
have not ever watched one episode and
what you know what
so much buzz around it I am going to
probably get the box set or trying to
find it on Netflix or Hulu or whatever
someone I'm sure will be streaming it
and start from a why I do kind of want
to see what all the talk was about yeah
I haven't seen an episode either but I'm
gonna get around to it maybe we can
watch it together you know you know what
I wouldn't be so honored if you and I
could just get some popcorn some Fritos
and just sit there and just veg out
let's have all the dads and we could
just like to have a session that would
be so awesome
do you have a big TV I mean things like
that I do we do what do you get well
TV like if it wasn't the man cave oh
yeah that's a shadow yeah that is Greek
freak was quoted in a New York Times
article two years ago I'm a low-profile
guy I don't like all these flashy cities
like LA or Miami I don't know if I could
be the same player if I played in those
cities there's also a little chatter
that just started to leak out that maybe
you could get Kyrie Irving and LeBron
together again in Los Angeles if he
doesn't end up in New York how do you
think that would work out did this Kyrie
on one at all ever yeah that I've heard
and I think people are always going to
allude to that conversation when Kyrie
called up during the middle of the
season this year and you know basically
apologize for being a terrible teammate
not listening so I'm sure people are
going to especially Laker fans they're
gonna kind of hold on to that hope that
reunion happens I can see that I
absolutely could see those two you know
pairing up in Tinseltown and you know
trying to get the band back together
well but you have the fourth pick in the
draft you can take this garland kid out
of Vandy who's a good point guard or you
can trade Lonzo ball which they might do
both of those things I think there's
talk that maybe you get the Bulls
involved in a three-team deal where you
know Lakers Bulls and the pelicans and
then Anthony Davis somehow ends up with
the Lakers but if you added LeBron and
you've got Kyrie got rid of Lonzo and a
couple other players brought in Anthony
Davis you'll get people's attention in
the West so uh absolutely if you put
Anthony Davis LeBron and Kyrie wouldn't
you have to say they're the odds-on
favorite in the Western Conference
again I'm not quite sure that New
Orleans is going to deal with the with
the Lakers with Anthony Davis I still
don't see that I just think they're
gonna be bullheaded and if anything took
him out west and if he chooses once his
contracts over to go to LA that's on him
I just don't see Orleans and the Lakers
doing finding any type of viable trade
to get Anthony Davis okay but if
I said right now that the Lakers have
Anthony Davis they have LeBron and Kyrie
and they lose all of the younger players
and let's say Golden State loses Kevin
Durant favorite the Lakers would be a
bigger favorite than Golden State with
no Kevin Durant absolutely hmm okay
because I could I could find players in
the jeely to surround those guys
absolutely because you just need
shooters after that yeah but the Lakers
didn't flying shooters read so why
didn't they surround LeBron with
shooters the first time around when he
needed the shooters well that would be a
Magic Johnson and a Rob palinka I agree
with you that even had the Bronte's on
your team you've got to have big men who
can stress the floor Chris Bosh Kevin
Love and you've got to have plenty
guards booby Gibson Kyrie Irving who can
just spread this floor and stay in the
corner and knock down shots that's your
job description hey if we win the when
we win this sports enemy tonight we're
gonna get you one thank you win yeah
well you know we're elminated but when
we win I'm gonna make sure you get one
of those sports Emmys we don't have a
game I'm gonna like it all year yeah I'm
gonna let you know right after the award
is and I think we might be the second
award that's announced tonight in either
way we lose in our category who is in
our category who are we up against
Rachel Nichols in the jump pardon the
interruption outside the lines MLB
tonight and I think that's it I think
our stiffest competition is outside the
lines and maybe pardon the interruption
for out of those shows be honest if you
were judge and I didn't know who you
voted for and you were looking at the
tapes who do you think you'd be voting
for
I would go with outside the lines one
[Laughter]
it's not I think it's down it's gonna
come down to outside the line Ritchie
didn't pick us I said it's 1a 1b it's
between us yeah but we were the be the a
was outside the lines if you ask me that
every point shooter in history is a
couple Michael Jackson song that beat
those B singles ended up being like mmm
where I hit reg when they say greatest
three-point shooter of all time I say
you even if I don't believe it I say you
but our stiffest competition is outside
the lines you ask that
okay that's who our stiffest competition
is is outside the line enjoy your night
on not worried about it maybe part of
the interruption Rachel I love you we
work together but you're not on our
level
Thank You reg you're the best
yeah yeah yeah that's the Reggie he's
right in our corner almost four more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]